ich begrüße zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir wie schon angekündigt
die tagung die letzten freitag
stattgefunden hatte nach besprechen
freundin für die identitäts tagung und
möchte auch noch ein rückblick geben auf
die letzte sitzung die sitzung vor zwei
wochen wo wir ganz verschiedene
interessante dinge gemacht hatten
nämlich uns mit dem thema diese version
beschäftigt haben
dimension ist eine ganz interessante
spannende ästhetische kategorie nicht
nur noch und sie sehen dass man mit
dieser kategorie sofort an die
computerspiele verließen ist nach
computerspielen
das ist so zentrum das heißt nicht dass
sie immer nur durch computerspiele
bekommen
dann könnten auch in version erhalten
wenn sie zb sich einen kinofilm
anschauen und den so mitreißen finden
dass sich dinge rein versetzen oder wenn
sie ein buch lesen und so gefangen
genommen werden dass sie fast schon
selbst sich als teil dieser geschichte
fühlen kann neben benzin zu warm werden
können sie gerne hin wenn das fenster
aufmacht das dürfen sie dann in kraft
ich habe es dazu gemacht wie des
sommerfestes war hier ein bisschen mehr
- aber sie entscheiden
wir haben jetzt momentan zwei zuschauer
wir haben und kein leid jetzt haben wir
ein like und jetzt mach doch mal kurz an
die ästhetik der computerspiele der
gesamten version ist und weiter begriff
ich mache es so kurz mindestlohn ist
halle 14
bei den personen haben wir hier
ziel ist es computerspiele ist auch
nicht den konnte kurzfassung eines
speziell computer spielen zu wissen das
und haben das ist ein besonders
intensives spiel weil es der die rolle
von terroristen oder von counter
terrorist als polizei- oder stk
ich weiß nicht was alles übernehmen und
aus der ich-perspektive angestiegen sei
die sache dann vorsichtig
das natürlich diesen 3d shooter die sind
besonders geeignet für die version weil
sie nämlich simulieren glücklich
perspektive also sie versetzen sich dann
in diese perspektive des jeweiligen
spielers ich zeige ja auch noch mal ein
paar noch ein durchgang diese
verschiedenen runterspielen das letzte
mal hatte das heißt für mich dass sie
die version nur realisieren können
wir sind personen respektive häufig
mangelt es sogenannte schottern oder 3d
ballerspielen an tiefe an gehalt muss
mit der story oder der geschichte das
heißt hier wird die version erst ins
innere technische riss durch die
perspektive die der linie diejenigen die
dieses spiel spielt es geht auch nicht
viele die gar nichts
es hat mir seine zweite sollte also
nicht aus ersten person sondern der
dritten person ja als oder sogar aus der
ersten person wir wo sie verschiedene
personen steuerung spiel von oben
gesehen und solche spiele sind häufig
rollenspiels diablo sein herz kommt ihr
bei die auch und viersen und das ist ein
spiel massiv verhoben sehen und das
überzeugt vor allem durch seine
geschichte der dritte teil vielleicht
nicht so auch der zweite erst als sie
können immer so nicht müssen nicht nur
durch
diese 3d sind sie können es dann endlich
am computer spielen
sie haben literatur und sie haben sogar
auch chance musik ist musik kann sie
auch im
sie erfassen und wichtig richtig
einbeziehen das ist einfach nur eine
frage wie sehr man diesen spielern oder
den rezipienten an seinen versuchen
version ist ein verhältnis von
präsentieren
das kommt den staat weiß ich auch mal
aufarbeiten
und medien und das entscheidende ist
natürlich die tendenziell die zuschauer
dürfen jetzt hier gerne widersprechen
rohstoffen flaig sie auch wenn sie ein
bisschen plakativ gesagt musik oder film
oder fernsehen ist relativ passiv
ich sitze im sessel ich sitze irgendwo
die sitze in bayreuth auf dem hauptplatz
stuhl zur bisher wenig mit wagner opern
hand und ich nehme auf und selbst wenn
man nur wird es nach einem
kritisieren der aufnehmende die aufnimmt
ist heißt es nicht dass nicht alles so
möglich sie können sich durch das auch
hineinversetzen das ganze mitverfolgen
und jetzt muss man noch korrigieren
musik hören oder fernsehen nur passiv
sondern dem sie rezitieren werden sie
aktiv also wahrnehmung ist nicht etwas
passendes wahrnehmung ist nur gesteuert
von ihm selektiv so wie es jeder will
anders musste jeder hat andere
interessen mit denen sich diesem stück
öffnet das heißt musik höre es immer
auch etwas tun dass es nicht nur
schleusen öffnen oder uhr auf und ab ist
es 1
zur wahrnehmung ist wesentlich komplexer
fast schon gewöhnt natürlich ist
tendenziell musik höre ihr eine passive
angelegenheit und anders verhält es sich
mit dem computerspiel wie sehe ich auch
den computerspieler als in ttt er als
ein akteur fassen würde
das ist ein ganz ganz spannende frage
welchen status hat der computerspieler
die computer spielerinnen passiven
rezipienten irgendwie nicht mehr so
rezipiert zwar das spiel zu jeder zeit
gehalten
aber sie gestaltete story mit und häufig
gibt es spiele wo es keinen
vorgezeichneten weg geben es gibt zwar
zb spiele wie monkey island kennen sie
das werk bank ihr einen der in admont
allem eins gespielt haben auch im 2
gespielt das war das beste in meinen
augen werden und einen 3 gespielt ist 3d
spielen gut welchen fand sie am besten
ok also zum beispiel beim alten es ist
so oder gibt es da kann man da mussten
häufig besuchen das ist so ein bisschen
adventure erscheint electric spielen wo
sie eine piratentochter schicken egal ob
street tribut
wo sie den spiegel stellen oder 2d welt
oder betreiben und sie müssen bestimmte
rätsel wir müssen und diese rätsel
lassen sich häufig nur auf ein oder zwei
bestimmte anzahl von anzahl weisen lösen
das heißt wenn sie das spiel lösen oder
durchspielen dann folgen sie einem
primitiven im gange sie haben nicht
unendlich viele möglichkeiten dieses
spiel zu gestalten
anders ist es bei dem spiel mediators
zufallsgenerator mitzubringen jedes
spiel anders zwei andere entitäten im
spiel auftauchen weil die geheimnisse
die verstecke bei jedem spiel zum anders
angeordnet werden per zufallsgenerator
dh
die videospiele vorgezeigt
den terminiert sind und mit dem ofen
sendung idealfall ist ins spiel so dass
jedes spiel dieses spiels jedes hier den
aktualisierungen des spiels in sich
hinein geben die anders ist ein kleines
individuell nur vom amateur abhängt es
ist alles so die die zukunft und da ist
gibt es schon viele spiele bei denen das
leben so dass anders und das ist die
spannende frage welche wurde er der welt
zu gehen
die spielerin sie ist nicht nur klassik
sieben aktiven mitgliedschaft ist hier
der alte geschichte und dann zimmer an
der frage inwiefern handelt es sich dann
um virtuelle realität
dann würde ich sagen ab einem bestimmten
grad der bestimmt komplexität oder auch
in nord andere spieler mit diesen
schlüssen wäre ich bereit von den wird
schwere themen zu sprechen
ich wäre es noch nicht wenn er sich nur
eine simulation handelt wenn da jemand
fifa 95 79
sich werden die für 97 familien noch
gespielt wir 95 60 also wenn dessen
jemand spielt dann würde ich sagen es
eine simulation dann ist es nicht eine
virtualität man könnte jetzt
argumentieren die rallye selbst gab an
sein spiel so nico d grafik hat in der
so komplex dann könnte man von
virtueller realität sprechen ich bin
skeptisch ich würde sagen dass es eine
bessere simulation realität bekommen
spielen weiter auch erst dann wenn
andere frei ist liegt mit spielen und
wir das ganze austragen so dass eine
verbindlichkeit entsteht
wir können darüber ungünstigen reden
sind allerlei waren letzten
unterscheiden sich computerspiele von
anderen formen von spielen und
kulturellen produkten wie literatur film
muss ich es auch tun also für das sagen
durch die aktivität der involviert haid
des akteurs sie können wir können
darüber diskutieren
das sind meine thesen was bedeuteten
version da ist es also eintauchen das
einbeziehen
wir beziehen uns computerspiele mit
einem da der bei drei grad auf zu
sprechen kommen die man ihnen ein in dem
der rezipient der akteur eine arbeit
haben
die figur aber trauer steuert übernimmt
repräsentiert und durch verschiedene
ästhetische mittel also durch grafiken
durch tönen das ist die frage nato
mitteln und jetzt die spannende frage
und verstellen kann unterschiedliche
virtuelle realitäten und nicht einfach
nur simulationen infektionen ich meine
these wir können darüber diskutieren
auch bitte hier auf youtube nur zwei
zuschauer zufrieden die meisten meiner
zuschauer haben jetzt wahrscheinlich
besseres zu tun
die gehen jetzt die englische gaben
schlafend oder nicht mehr kommen aus der
ganzen welt
also ich würde sagen computerspiele sind
in der regel über simulation sehr gut
gemachte sehr fantasiereiche
simulationen oder vielleicht auch
infektionen das sind stories dessen
erzählungen künstliche welten die
arbeitsplanung wie keine realität haben
in meinen augen war realität mehr
verbindlichkeit und auch mehr kausale
kraft voraus setzt die nicht nur dadurch
erzielt ist dass das spiel auf mich
irgendwie psychologisch wird dass ich
jetzt so diese aufzubringen habe und
dass uns stärker auf unser an meter
simuliert wird das dann
der höhe gewinnt und über zwei
hochhäuser das ist eine illusion die
erzeugt wird eine fiktion simulation die
mich psychisch oder sinne in den zustand
versetzt als ob ich da jetzt laufen
würde und zudem sprechen finde ich so
aber es hatte keine medizin also ich
glaube es ist stark ich glaube erst dann
bekommt das eine realität wenn hand der
vws interagieren und wenn es eine
verbindlichkeit verbindlichkeit die
stabilität in ordnung darstellt das wäre
so meine these also wir müssen aufpassen
wenn wir von virtueller realität
sprechen ich glaube dieser begriff wird
häufig verwendet für komplexe 700 zu ich
glaube dass es halt was einst in kärnten
james-bond-film wissen spiel vorgestellt
worden
der erschien strom staaten kommt wenn
man ihn richtig
sind sind sogar der meinung
was dann wir würden
die tür
gewissen bezug auf ja also ich würde es
ein wunder punkt ich würde sagen da ein
beiden eben darauf nur simuliert wird da
gibt es eben mehr stimulieren
es gibt zb dem raum bad bank für die
sony playstation wer hat den bremer pack
oder von der emittent um 64 werden mit
dem rabatt von ihnen nicht sehr gut
sammelpunkt wissen sie erklären sie mal
konzert ihren 100
man steckt und wenn man
damit spielen
hallo
genau das dann die haptische oder
physische der spieler hat von den martin
kapp 64 gespielt sehr gut
wer dann geht es bei mario kart 64 immer
daran die in die kollision hat er hat
dann könnte es zum beispiel das nach nur
simulation würde ich sagen das sind
keine realität obwohl natürlich hier die
kausalität stärker bisher wird flüssig
mehr auf was vermittelt aber es ist eine
illusion wirklich sagen also realität
wird im anders fassen realität würde ja
als eine vertrauensbasis und interaktive
verbindlichkeit bestimmen wie sie bei
geld der fall ist geld das jetzt nicht
digitalisierten auch im bitcoins also
man braucht sich das gar nicht so sehr
diese wirkung jetzt vorstand legt sich
auf mich ausübt sahen hier inszeniert
diese verbindlichkeit dass es eine geld-
und normativität ein wert der sich damit
was machen kann wenn ich liefern
ich weiß nich 2008 und 18 19 dieses
fußballspielen alleine spiele gegen den
computer dann habe ich den fußball
simulationen künstlich
die längste eingesetzt wird wenn die
fifa online spiele und ein ranking
system rankings system teilnehmen und
sehr gut und kann ich damit geld machen
wenn ich da regelmäßig gewinne anders
ganz anders
wir werden zeigen wo andere spieler
gegen mich antreten wird es nicht mehr
nur das simulation sondern ist das ernst
dann wird fußball auch wenn es irgendwie
simuliert ist wird es weil es
verbindlichkeiten eröffnet und nicht
mehr nur auf der simulationsergebnisse
befindet es geht nicht mehr darum dass
ich so tue als ob ich fußball spielen
würde
es geht um was neues ich spiele
irgendwie ein spiel aber das ist ein
computerspiel und dass es nicht mehr nur
abhängig von der simulation
es geht hier um gewisse gelder oder
gewisse den ranglisten es geht auch um
werte die verhandelt werden fähigkeiten
die gemessen das wäre zu meinen thesen
also wie fern kann virtuelle realitäten
version bestätigt wird sagen es geht
aber nicht auf es kann sein dass
virtuelle realität mit
zu tun hat sicherlich aber es hält mich
davon ab würde ich sagen
bitcoin oder andere es gibt auch
computerspiele die sehr abstrakt centro
ganz wenig mehr so eine rolle spielt gut
ich bin natürlich irgendwie dann
involviert aber es ist nicht abhängig
von dem grad der technik die ich auf
wenn zum beispiel könnte
auf online-spiele dieses dieses
primitive spielen online spielen und
hätte dann auch eine virtualität die ja
gut die schon in version hat weil ich
eben nicht sehr hineinversetzen
aber ich glaube was auseinanderhalten
jetzt geht es noch mal rückblickend ich
mir dafür mühe gemacht hat ich möchte
ihnen einfach nochmal präsentieren
die kleine geschichte der evolution der
computerspiele bin sie begeben sich
jetzt auf eine zeitreise und wir wollen
uns hier folgen dieses zeige diese
kurzen sequenzen und zu überlegen wie im
version jeweils realisiert wird durch
und durch bewegung durch gute aktionen
durch figuren avatar gesteuert und durch
nicht verhältnis das finde ich ein ganz
wichtig wir haben jetzt hier nicht die
möglichkeit akustisch das auch noch
wiederzugeben und dann eben die frage
simulation fiktion eine virtuelle
realität meine these grafik sein ehrlich
bedeutet
steht haben die frage diese modifikation
illusion der hamas sind kandidat das
kann man sich entschieden
das kennen sie das habe eine spezielle
version verlangt weil jetzt auch das
setzen von ca alles ist vom wissen aus
welchem jahr
ich habe mir hatte er ein teilnehmer und
teilnehmerinnen zeichen geschrieben
dieses spiel passiert auf einer viel
älteren version aus den 40er 50er
eigentliches gewechselt werden wo es
eigentlich im ersten vorlauf ihre
persönlichen appell den markt
als books auf dem markt selbst dann
weitere abänderung demnächst zum
beispiel rahmen zu sehen und das 10
system das tanzstudio
die beziehung ich finde es ein sehr
simples spiel aber irgendwie habe es
sehr gerne gespielt kennt jemand
commander geben ja kann man da kann man
das auch spielen die konsole
das ist integriert ja das ist dann eben
schneller ursprünglich und das ist jetzt
kann man erkennen wie das spiel gespielt
lohnt sich gibt's jetzt auf steam als
schleichwerbung summer sale alle für
alle
alle verfolgen für zwei dollar oder 21
weil es wird schon vorbei ist das hier
sind hier sehen sie jetzt diskutieren
wir darüber was mit ihren versionen
werden dass sie das immer die
sendefrequenz die chinesische version
wie können sich hier einfach keiner
versetzen
was wird sie spielen jetzt die figur wir
sind dieser klub diesen fällen
ist diese nicht geschenke habe dieser
bei diesen themen und der bildschirm
folgt ihnen wenn sie laufen folgt der
bildschirm die bewegung so dass der satz
das geschehen zwar disko no
die veränderten version ist
mg gestalterischen möglichkeiten haben
die programmierer eingesetzt
erst mal sagen jetzt im vergleich zu
kommen wenn man etwas menschen englisch
ist gut das leidige wurden genau genau
das schon mal hektisch und zwar so in
der regel haben dass auch kinder
gespielt ab 10 jahren oder so ich habe
es auch später als ich zehn jahre alt
war und ich konnte mich mit dem wir
haben auch ein bisschen besser
identifizieren aber selbst jetzt handys
mit 35 spiele oder spielen sollte könnte
ich mich damit identifizieren auf welche
weise das wäre dass die möglichkeit die
identifikation
also es ohne metro ist als erinnerung
und retro das ist der metro kult der
grad zerstört
aber nicht nur das man kann diese figur
sympathisch finden
man kann sie lustig finden interessant
finden hat einfach diese diese figur weg
gezeigt es jetzt nicht nur hier sie ist
ja praktisch ziemlich schlecht erkennen
sie ist sehr nah pixel und kann es
irgendwie originell oder ihrem in ihrer
darstellung in die stimmung ist damit
sie passt eben das ganze gefüge
wie kann man sich noch identifizieren
immerhin im e mail also intensiv
einbezogen
das genau die welt folgt die welt folgt
dem der content dem befehl dem eingang
und das ist dann der nächste schritt
wäre dann die 3d perspektive die also
die die westlich bringt sich im blick
schweiz da sind alle richtungen auf dem
boden
wenn der nach unten blickt steckte kurz
runter da geht der bildschirm an unten
also scrollt man kann man runter
schrauben wieder nach oben schaut wieder
machen das ist die 2d realisierung von
etwas was man damals eben nicht auf 3d
machen konnte
die wartenden seien tagsüber suchen
[Musik]
in seinem leben haben und selber mit
genau als es die wird auch seine dritte
person wie ist er durch sprechen die
figur mit er aber man könnte auch sagen
es ist wieder eine erste besserung ich
und er es ist eine verbindung zwischen
erste und dritte weil ich habe mit
commander keen ich bin bis level sohn so
bekommen
ich habe es im speed plan haben sie es
schon als speedrun geschaut und müsst
sie mal schauen sie mal commander käme 4
ein youtube speed verein ist der
wahnsinn wie schnell dass es schon an
bedeutung man spielt dieses spiel mit
dem interesse der kürzestmöglichen zeit
fertigzustellen
und da kommt dann eher so ein aspekt der
virtuellen realität ein spiel weil dann
geht es um verbindlichkeit ich würde
immer noch sagen ist die simulation aber
dann machen wir aus dem spiel war es
ganz anders wir spielen es mit einem
ganz anderen interessen
gelernt hat sie auch dieses jahr ist
genau wie sie in versionen geben
ich habe nur für dich zu verdienen heißt
es in berlin
mails von fanseiten dem spiel
eigentlich reichen sollen
die aktion daten werden später dann
suchen wir den orders teilweise nicht
die besucher sich ein programmpunkt wozu
jetzt schauen was ist eigentlich eine
band zu gründen und diese ein irgendwie
ausgeglichen so genau kennen sie jeder
switch ja also man kann zum beispiel die
switches außen streaming software oder
streaming portal ähnlich wie youtube
was wir jetzt gerade auf youtube haben
kann man auch auf einer eigenen
plattform machen auf der man nur
computerspiele streams sowie seminaren
stream und dass die hat es gibt sehr
viele zuschauer haben könnte zum
beispiel commander keen sri trang live
streamen
und dann gelingt gibt es kommentare und
so weiter da haben wir schon gewissen
grade aber ein anderer bogen zieht diese
figur kann der presse kann schauen ja
erst anschließend gewisse eigenschaften
sie haben eine pistole wie kann mit
diesen figuren hinter hier zählt jetzt
gerade die schnecke und dieses diesen
ball war bewusstlos geschossen wir
liegen jetzt bei sehen
staffel dann muss man drüber springen
oben gibt es auch solche form von
niemann 1 - und wieder hier oben zählen
das ist die lehre die man nach dass die
helme sind die pistolenschüsse die man
hat wie das sind die die regentropfen im
sonstigen wertgegenständen
der commander keen sammelt süßigkeiten
ein da gibt es einen schokoladen tafeln
gibt es große bonbons haben einer
bestimmten anzahl von 1 gesammelten
süßigkeiten kriegt ein zusätzliches
levels ist als seite helfen
zahlen müssen auch noch dieses element
here lebensdauer bei anderen spielen
gibt es die lebensbalken gibt es hier
nicht das problem dieses spiels ist wenn
sie einmal von der schnecke berührt
wären ohne diesen die sind diesen haufen
hier ein drehten dann ins kaputt also
müssen sie das spiel neubeginn
andere spieler haben das zu kritisiert
dass der avatar an lebens wagen hat das
ist so eine statusleiste dass die kann
gefüllt sein und haben sieben prozent
leben und sie kann aber auch gerade
werde reduziert werden das ist auch eine
möglichkeit die version sich selbst mit
der gesunden gesundheitszustand
avatar zu einander verhältnis und sagen
jetzt haben wir noch zehn lebensenergie
jetzt muss ich aufpassen
man sagt mich derart nur noch zehn
prozent energie ich würde sagen ich habe
die seiten schriften zu reißen was zb
diese lebensweise sind keine
einheitliche sagt dass das heißt es
nämlich im eigenen bogen gebe es ab und
zu selbst zu den schnellsten zehn
prozent mehr regen darstellen das sind
dargestellt und irgendwann sind erst nur
so viel ich habe das gerade so über
stein gemeißelten kirchen harmlose für
kinder und senioren zu bauen und das
würde für simulationen sprechen was
jetzt erwägen in mainkofen weniger für
virtuelle realität aber natürlich
weiterer punkt ist sie können dann
austüfteln wie viel schaden was
verursacht als wenn ich jetzt gar anders
spielen über den haufen eintreten könnte
das erfahrungsgemäß in einer bestimmten
bandbreite im range können es
punkteabzug
und da gibt es also dass die eigene
wissenschaft für sich getroffen haben
nach einfach mal weiter kann man kinder
hat das commander keen 4 ist es gibt
verschiedene 5 1 also 29
wolfenstein 3d es war ganz schön
schwierig ein aussteller zu finden der
kein hakenkreuz aufweist wenn ich dann
hagen kurzfilm gehabt hätte er nämlich
viel zugehört also große probleme geben
dieses spiel ist aber kein nazi spiels
an diesen spielen kämpft man gegen nazis
als also einige insofern ist
problematisch aber es war infiziert wie
eine zeit aufgrund der verschiedenen
verwendeten zu bohren und das jetzt die
letzte szene wo sie aus der ersten
person perspektive die sie gleich am
anfang kurz hinter pistole vorne
jetzt von der kommen sie dann in die
dritte person perspektive
das ist die einzige sequenz des ganzen
spiels ist die endsequenz wo sie
horizont jetzt gleichen dieses grüne
sehen
das ist der ausgang da springen sie aus
dem schluss dass das schloss wolfenstein
kassel wo wir stehen und da springen sie
da draußen haben es geschafft hat sich
durchgekämpft und dieses spiel ist zum
ersten mal zu eines der ersten spiele wo
sie so eine 3d wählen simuliert bekommen
hatten die aber eben nur auf einer ganz
raffinierten von 192 selben jahre
commander keen
das ist aber die rating oder ray tracing
technologie wo 72
das muss immobilien in dem sie strahlung
aussenden im avatar unternehmen messen
wie weit das wände entfernt
die man eben die weite strahlend in die
mine zu treffen die bei anderen
kleineren
es wird kleiner und dann wird das noch
ein konzert ein bisschen dieser
positionierte das gold der fluss regen
ist an fluglinien einbezieht und dann
bekommen sie eben so was raus und das
hier sind schon sehr aussetzungen 3d
diese band den zweiten finalisten ist
meine form zurück sehen sie die
performance sehen glaube man die diese
geräte und genau so wird es auch mit
dieser reform die 12
natürlich fehlt sie noch die
abschreibung werde das land ins unglück
und es müsste also wir müssen noch ein
bisschen perspektiven weil die
perspektivisch verzerrt werden
und dann haben sie sehr schnell den
eindruck einer 3d welt die aber durch
zwei mal durch zweidimensionale technik
reduziert wird das ist eine
projektionsfläche
selber
deshalb weisen von einer seite gemacht
werden sich diese an bord gegeben sich
dieses bereiches gemacht
genau das ist also mit maps 3d figuren
werden hier gar nicht dargestellt wenn
sie dadurch war und von den läufern zu
teilen zum zurückhaben
dann sehen sie denn nicht nur von einer
perspektive es gibt meistens 304
verhindern kann man sehen
eine von der seite oder ich weiß nicht
viel über eine begrenzte anzahl von
seiten und er hat irgendwie sich zu
diesem zu dieser entität verhalten also
aus der perspektive diese zu verstehen
zeigt sich von einer seite wenn sie ein
bisschen drumherum gehen dann klappt das
und geht auch für nächste seite 7
köstlich aus andere spiele sind genug im
3d und tun die ganzen spiele auch die
haben bereits also jetzt wenn ich zwei
die figuren die nicht geändert sind um
diese nicht herumlaufen können die
verschiedenen abschattungen also ganz
spannend das jetzt tun dass sie sich
schon deutlich gesagt da könnte es sogar
darunter
hier sehen sie die laufen gezogen holen
sich dass die panzer muss durch
überzeugung sagen wir selektieren ist
die am modus und inventionen
gesundheitstage sehen sie jetzt es geht
jetzt gerade runter und die gesundheit
wird mit diesem gesicht fast völlig
symbolisiert wenn es noch 50 prozent hat
sie dieser kopf her sehr mitgenommen aus
hier haben sie über nachrüstung und hier
haben sie die ganzen statistiken wie
viel also zur detail statistik und hier
oben sehen sie nach objekt ab aber sie
haben ganze rüstung aufgebot
da aus zu nachrichten bereit sie können
oft oben aus fenster schauen uns jetzt
mal schauen und sehen sie aus dem
fenster die berge konzerns gesehen also
ist ein aus preiswertes etwa 100 so 2d
texturen 193 riesen vorstellt und
douglas ist gar nicht mit der raiders
dem engine als mit diesem strahlend
technik erzeugt mehr antreten das
projekt ist sehr schlecht
überspringt
dass das erste spiel wo sie keine
spreads als gegner hatten sondern wir
alle wie vor dem spiel
dreidimensional realisiert waren dass
eine meilenstein viele spiele die es
heutzutage noch gibt basieren auf diese
engine von 1996 das muss ich mir
überlegen engine ist als der motor ist
die technologie die grafiktechnologie
ein bisschen zu spät
das ist an deinen sohn haben übrigens
nicht so gut das war diese geschichte
die sie gern musik
diese wichter jeden nachmittag ausgehen
das war eines der ersten spiele was mit
exzellente nicht
ganz liebes aus vielen draußen und die
der gerne sogar
aus sagt und dann sind sie in den
völligen dunkel gehüllt und dann kommt
ein gegner wissen sie welcher gegner
heißen bei am leben
das kam so mancher skr idiot oder soja
distanz ohne und außerirdische monster
und das attackiert ein damen- und zwar
mit einer sehr groß motivieren wenn man
aufs schießen springt es zur seite ich
erinnere mich noch sehr gut an die
situation war aber in meinen augen und
keine virtuelle vibriert sondern er sehr
gut dass simulation aber als wirklich
sehr gut mit weißem 198 und das ist
jetzt ihr anwalt engine 4
und so haben sie dazu noch bemerkt kürze
nochmal die letzte thematik also ich
glaube in version und virtuelle realität
sind hänge miteinander zusammen wir
sollten virtuelle realität nicht zu weit
gebrauchen
wir sollten weil wir uns gewisse
dimensionen verbauen nämlich wirklich
ökologische eigenständige entitäten die
durch simulation nicht erzielt wird
ich habe präsident jetzt noch ein
bisschen zu meinem vortrag von dieser
tagung dass es an italien haben sie den
bisschen mitverfolgen können sie finden
die alle noch auf youtube also auf
lokales können sich die ganzen vorträge
anschauen das war eine tagen wo es auch
darum gehen wie führen
diese digitalen medien die digitale
technologien unser lernen und lehren
verhindern können
und ich habe hier so ein paar leitfragen
parität das haben wir schon mit dem
felix stalder wie verhalten die sich
zueinander nicht einfach nur kurzen
durch lauf geben denn felix stalder der
dieses buch kultur der digitalität
geschrieben den hat der marcel der hier
und so erstmals seien auch interviewt
sie können das interview auch auf sehen
ja das interessiert mich eben auch dass
im pädagogischen perspektiven
sie sehen auch gerade jetzt diese
momente ist experiment was ich
festgestellt habe ist dass die cic also
es gibt jetzt in diesem seminar zu hause
ein bisschen rückblickend gab es einige
kommentare aber selten live als ausgaben
da ich bin darauf eingegangen aber was
mir aufgefallen ist es dass die
diskussion zum beispiel auf twitter
wesentlich lebendiger muss auf twitter
twittern ist das medium wo man sich
wissenschaftlich auch bevorzugt auszeit
war mir lange zeit ins gericht ist man
ja auch politiker bringen
alle wissen wenn er wieder mal jemand zu
schnell ein trio abgesetzt nachhinein
widerrufen muss ich glaube twitter hat
eine viel größere verbindlichkeit es
viel akzeptierter mit bezug auf die
diskussion
das heißt man müsste eigentlich parallel
hierzu twitter kommunizieren und schauen
was die leute ihren platzes sagen
während nicht dass hier erhalte also ich
glaube dass youtube tatsächlich nicht so
gut geeignet ist um zu diskutieren
das habe ich jetzt gemerkt da muss man
anderes andere plattformen einsetzen da
kann es im nachhinein diskussion aber
scheint es nicht so gut zu funktionieren
weil man halt nicht so gut dann mit
hashtags und kann das natürlich auch
kein vergnügen
rauschen hier vor drei jahren die
entweder ist er fliegen komplizierter
wird und besser gestaltet und besser
geeignet für so eine diskussion ja die
frage diskutiert dann felix stalder hat
den hat das buch geschrieben und oder
digital
bryan gewinnen ihren eingeführte
referenz realität gemeinschaften können
und alchemie zieht er betrachtet die
digitalisierung äußerst stark kultur
kultur theoretischen perspektive das ist
sicherlich sehr spannend was nicht die
besonders anfällige mannschaften die
kite dass ihm durch
verbindungen hergestellt werden kann
dass die kommunikation eine neue
dimension bekommt die kommunikation
transformieren
das glaube ich schon auch bedeutungen
das was wichtig ist der verletzte hat
jemand sich bezieht das sind wieder in
die sache
[Musik]
es gab dann auch im gefolge dieser
tagung eine recht interessante
diskussion auf twitter ich will's
konzept erzählen da hatte dann jemand
gegen ende hin eben gesehen dass einige
bilder ins internet gestellt auf twitter
wo man eben die vortrags vor den zahlen
zu antworten
gestellt er stand zu stand ihren dann
kam ein kommentar das scheint aber
eigentlich der digitalität thematik zu
widersprechen hier ist ein frontaler
vortrag also die tage bis heute um die
einen einsatz der armee die
transformation der lehre geben
und jetzt steht hier irgendjemand vorne
folien das ist doch total klasse dieses
total
jawohl school das war so ein kritischer
beitrag
das war von jemand der nicht an der
tagung teilgenommen hatte dann habe ich
eben geschrieben
das ist nur ein aspekt dieses ganze zu
haben wir haben hier daneben auf der
twitter-seite garantieren wird bald
wieder diskussionen ja auch
kommunizieren und wir haben das ganze
weile ertragen auf youtube
das wurde gar nicht richtig gesehen
wurde
oder verwenden der arminia extra auf auf
folien verzichtet um sich sagen normal
davon abzugehen
bisher auch ganz nett thematisiert so
weit
genau das mache jetzt oben rechts den
link zum axel kammerer hat einen sehr
engagierten vortrag gehalten
oben rechts hier in dem video jetzt
danach also der hat das ganz bewusst
darauf verzichtet haben also es noch
nicht das ende der fahnenstange
es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten die
leute zu aktivieren zb was es gibt es
solche geräte fernsteuerungen wo die
teilnehmer dann interagieren können wo
man zb umfragen macht das wird häufig
jetzt eingesetzten der mathematik dass
man den studierenden eine mathematische
aufgabe stellt die frage stellt wie sie
erstmalig direkt beantworten können der
konzern zeit wahnsinnig sie können es
nicht ausrechnen
diese koste zeit wie soll der vermutung
abgeben also wird dieser drei
antwortmöglichkeiten das richtig und
dann durften sie an stimmen und dann
gibt es wird nach den gründen seiner
damit das ergebnis eingepennt wie viele
leute für diese option gestimmt haben
das heißt man nimmt intuition direkt auf
und kommuniziert viel mehr
das muss jetzt nicht nur durch digitale
technik realisiert werden können aber es
ist eine möglichkeit an teilen noch mehr
mit einzubeziehen
ja also wie gesagt und ich habe jetzt
ebenso bisher die these vertreten und
wir kommen auf der nächsten sitzung auch
jetzt ausdrücklich zu sprechen und der
digitalität alles unter nur gb 6 1 das
hat das ganze
felix schneider sagt noch mal kurz
zurückspringen der sagt digitalität ist
die neue sphären die sich an die
gutenberg galaxis anschluss die
gutenberg galaxis war eine produktion
der schrift des buchdrucks die
beweglichen lettern mit dem man ganz
flexibel schrift organisieren konnte mit
all den konsequenzen politischer und er
sagt so wie die guttenberg revolution
die welt verändert hat so verändert
jetzt die digitalisierung die welt mit
ihrem volk ja was soll das
nur
in diensten der zweck heiligt komme das
verschieben für die aussprache zwischen
krankenhäuser direktion endlich die
möglichkeit und kommunikation wird die
wirklichkeit das heißt und irgendwie
wissen verwendet und kommunizieren dass
bedingungen auch schaffen können was es
zu bedeuten wenn ich jetzt bei denen wir
das geld jetzt haben sie das ersparte
schrift war vielleicht die fragen werden
demnach zum beispiel das radio
gerade moderne telekommunikation hier
schon erste schritte in diese richtung
gestellt haben uns nicht auf eine andere
quelle die chance zum 3 das handy auch
schon große vorteil im kampf gegen die
nazis mit dem zugesehen dass rechnungen
kommunikationsmethode
wenn sich nicht der befriedigung aus
gekommen so also mit radtour es
zumindest eben gut abgedeckte sagen es
wird so ein bisschen unabhängig vom raum
zu schicken die mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
über den atlantik und pazifik und die
ganze welt um in sekundenbruchteilen
diesen armen diesen argumenten
da hätte man das vielleicht ein punkt
wäre ein punkt hätte man mithalten
der auf der digitalen technik entspricht
internet gezogen haben ist ja auch nicht
mehr oder weniger lichtgeschwindigkeit
pings und so weiter machst vor
also ja aber ich glaube was sie bei der
grad der nicht alles ist dieses
interaktionsmöglichkeiten
sie zeigen
ich würde mich wie das sagen das radio
ist trotzdem noch sehr konventionell es
hat eine dimension nämlich die
reibungslose kite dieses geschwindigkeit
aber von der struktur her verfährt ist
eigentlich ganz traditionell mit
weltlicher meinung eigentlich das medium
sich in seine zeit oben davon dass eine
genfer sich eher auf eine andere liga
gesellschaft orientieren sich nicht
jedes jahr leisten sind
aber das ist es nicht gegeben das ist
eigentlich ein vorteil ist
inhalt und letztlich auch nennen sind
arbeiter der kommunikationsebene weiß
nicht nur den großen worten
außerdem ist gut bei uns also
verfügbarkeit ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt der auch politisch immer wichtiger
wird ich hatte es satt auch gleich noch
hängt auf diesen folien dass das
internet dort grundbedürfnis geworden
ist die wasserstrom elektrizität usw
und genauso könnte man auch sagen mir
empfangbar kein chance wenn sie zum
beispiel kein handyempfang haben oder so
einem fall kann es kein internet
empfangen
auch kein radio und fernseher sind
abgeschnitten von dem informationsfluss
und die frage die sie jetzt noch
aufgeworfen haben es die nach dem
verhältnis von medium also der medial
seite und der ontologie ich glaube dass
doch das internet was sich jetzt
häufiger digitalität rechnen wer also
für mich ist kurz gesagt das internet
das gerade mal
wenn wir wissen wollen wie digitalität
was auch immer das jetzt ist dann sagt
er kurz zusammenfassen digitalisierung
ist die technische seite und digitalität
ist die kulturelle oder die lebenswelt
der seite wie die technik in unseren
alltag eingang findet und wie sie uns
transformiert als zb hier herrscht
diskriminieren digitalität diesen auto
und dann interview
hyper text auch schon eltern haben wir
darüber gesprochen über text mit sie auf
wikipedia in artikel lesen hypertext
gibt schon seit den siebziger oder ganze
bibliothek systemen usa wo sie auch über
solche verlinkt kommandant aufgekommen
sind
aber erst über das durch das internet
konnte über text seinem wesen gemäss
realisiert werden sich jetzt fragen
durch diese schnelligkeit
geschwindigkeit und die komplexität die
diesen gibt diese gewichtigkeit des
netzes und ich glaube wirklich dass die
tat jetzt nicht über das medium internet
erklärt wird es eine technische seite so
über die lebensform des internets da ist
ein beiheft zb ist huber links
übernehmen sind jetzt auch nicht nur der
technik zumindest eine form von den über
texte sind in form von
kommunikationsform
[Musik]
auf der tagung
das ist hier jetzt
die unterlagen werden
vielleicht haben wir diese meinung
in einen taumel setzen also inhalte in
wien konnte damit wohl
man kann sich beim zusammenstellen wie
kann man die erfahrungen zusammen
die möglichkeit die verschiedenen der
bus kommt texten die menschen mit
eingeflossen und die diskussion gekommen
dass das institut geht es uns um eine
tagung war das buch zusammen
[Musik]
zusammenstellung der themen zusammen
das letzte mal nachdenken könnte
wie kann das passt dann auch das letzte
veranstaltung scheint auch leute die die
fans bald zu gestalten und wir geben ja
darüber welche also sie haben schon
recht ich meine ich war auch erstaunt
dass so wenige leute fragen online
eingeweiht haben nur zwei fragen online
es gab mir die möglichkeit was ich so
als verarbeitung des in hand über
twitter warnung für die nachwelt die
sind groß die twitter man da hatte man
dass das wasser die reflexion eigentlich
dieser folie und kann entweder man die
das dann die kommentare direkt dazu das
war somit anbieten wird das fand eine
gute idee war
organisatorisch habe ich glaube es hat
auch jeder verstanden irgendwie als die
die ganz hinten zeitung lesen können
das hätte man vielleicht ein bisschen
explizit erwähnen können dass wir das
wirklich mit einbeziehen wollen ich
glaube das könnte das problem ist dass
sich
haben oder die thematik sich um sehr
komplexes gebiet handelt und dann sagen
wir mal
dann sollte man einen kommentar zur
nachgeben geben aber der vortragende
oder die diskutierenden sind da schon
wieder ein ganzes stück weiter bis ich
dann meinen kommentar mal wirklich
hinter stücken habe anders wäre es
natürlich wenn ich mich da wenn ich da
zu sprechen können also auch als als
nicht hat da teilnehmer im raum welt ist
es das schreiben offensichtlich das
würde ja auch diese
diese these stützen dass das internet
eine ganz andere formen mit dabei der
integration beispiel der buchdruck genau
da ist es also schwierig darauf zu
antworten oder in der frage zu stellen
die auch nicht missverstanden werden
wenn ich die diskussion einsteigen
dann brauche ich mich so umfassend bei
der bei der ersten these zu äußern dies
vielleicht schrift nicht machen müssen
uns dazu anmerken möchte also näher das
von den wandler eigentlich ganz gut
gefallen weil er das waren ja glücklich
oder oder auch thesen und auch beispiele
die in die richtung gehen in wie sie das
internet also von von der alten oder
der analogen welt abmelde
ich mache jetzt oben rechts den link zu
dem vortrag gibt philipp wampfler
reinhold den sie sich beziehen
ein schweizer lehrer und
medientheoretiker der sehr häufig im
kontext von twitterern so auftaucht auch
in diesem riese oder rätselten city mit
dem auch gleich korrespondierte während
der tagung damit doppelt interessant ist
zeigt dann schon dass auch die tagung
sagen wir mal in der realität oder eben
jetzt angekommen
also ich könnte ihn mal tiefer ihnen mal
noch ein paar
es hat jetzt machen könnten als nächstes
mal ein paar twitter meinungen dazu nach
dass ihr mal sehen wie das medien nicht
und machen das hat schon ein bisschen
wellen geschlagen also der weg zu hat
darauf geantwortet dann noch mal mit dem
wampfler hat gesagt er ist ein positiv
ist also wird sie jetzt nur an
statistiken als eigentlich positiv ist
und war ein bisschen kritisch habe ich
habe ich das aufgegriffen haben und
fertig ist dreht so eine positive ist
fragezeichen haben
er stellt 500 in form von der besetzung
ein und die totalität und zone oder dann
bei herrn professor überleben
dann habe ich mein geld kostet was hat
das mit digitalität zu tun
und dann habe ich gleich ein paar bugs
bekommen und so und ich habe dann auch
die ganzen des ganzen videos in den
playlisten habt gesagt hier können alle
videos nachgeschaut werden danach und
das hat dann 40 likes bekommen
20 mal wurde es geteilt es gab schon ein
gewisses mädchen rechung und dass wir
jetzt glaube ich glaube es ist jetzt ab
also aber es hat auf diese twitter ebene
durchaus in der betriebe gewisse
verbreitung gefunden und ich zeige ihnen
nächsten sitzung als nachtrag um das
ende jetzt abzusehen zürich abgeebbt da
gibt es immer noch ein paar
vorauszusagen rück bezüge er werde immer
so eine zusammenstellung hier zeigen auf
dass screenshots wo sie zehn meter auf
reagiert von einer gras eine kurze
dokumentation und das sieht man schon
dass da einiges das hat einiges
ausgelöst also ganz kurz auf um einen
kanal gezogen
drei tagen circa 100 neue abonnenten
bekommen es ist sehr viel sehr viel lob
hat der hat innerhalb von drei tagen 100
euro so viel bekomme ich normalerweise
in zwei monaten also man kann er es auch
quantitativ säge und auswerten
ich bringe das nächste mal mache in der
nachbereitung wohin gehen wir mal ein
bisschen hoffenheim etwas wie sich
ausgewählt mit dem positiven wie im
negativen ich zeige die kritischen
punkte und ich zeige wie darauf reagiert
wurde
aber so vielen dank für den hinweis ich
sehe das auch so man muss da noch viel
mehr machen aber ich habe das gefühl
dass nicht alle so
man braucht ein bisschen mediale
ausstattung und noch braucht die
richtigen kanäle und die müsste und auch
kommunizieren nicht glauben auch dass da
noch viel ganz unentschieden ist das
noch nicht herauskristallisiert hat
welches medium am besten gepasst ich
hatte mich geirrt ich dachte wirklich
auf youtube geht mehr
aber es wird nicht genutzt youtube
diskussion wird nicht genutzt
in solchen fällen sind es wird andere
über twitter gemacht offensichtlich ist
die wissenschaft mehr auf twitter
mittlerweile ausgerichtet als auf
youtube ich glaube youtube trifft alles
ein soziologisches thema youtube würde
ich sagen betrifft muss
können wir widersprechen nutzerinnen und
nutzer zwischen 12 13 und gleichzeitig
als im schwerpunkt zwischen vielleicht
sogar eher 15 und 50 60 ein schwerpunkt
und also mich interessiert vor allem das
unternehmen 15
während es viel mehr jüngere leute die
dann auf zb sind oder andere eigentliche
plattform ich glaub youtube trifft gar
nichts mehr junge leute und ich glaube
dass nutzerinnen und nutzer die er jetzt
im alter von professorinnen und
professoren sind also ich sage jetzt mal
40 plus 50 plus das die auch nehme auf
youtube geben
besonders die in der regel auf twitter
geben weil dem dazu viel oder zu viel
videos mit
das wäre so eine vermutung müssen wir
mal statistik bringt laut twitter ist
das medium wasser das alter von
professorinnen und professoren an sprich
von etablierten berufstätigen kleben
genutzten youtube wird glaube ich dann
so einem publikum von beruf etablierten
nutzerinnen gar nicht mehr so sehr muss
man habe vielleicht hängt das eben
mit meiner zwischenposition muss sagen
dass ich jetzt eben hirn einschalten
wer jetzt noch 100 youtube-nutzer falle
aber müsste man soziologischen aus
werden da gibt es auch statistiken ich
versuche das auch den nächsten sitzungen
garten
ja ich habe jetzt betreten hatten einige
unter
und ich kann die offene brutalität zu
stellen
wir sind sehr schön
freiheit also bald ist in kürze
virtuelle realitäten nur durch freiheit
ohne freiheit keine virtuelle realität
freiheit meint dass wir so wie das
subjektive verbund haben innerhalb
dessen er diese simulation oder was auch
immer eine kausale verbindlich sondern
hängt sie in der luft ist ohne illusion
es im nationalen reformen zur freiheit
wird auch virtualität in form zu
verleiten werden und zwar deswegen weil
virtualität eben bedeutet etwas auf eine
andere weise realisieren zu können als
es normalerweise getan
ich kann fußball spielen auf dem rad und
der handel borken gemacht
im dreidimensionalen raum ich kann es
aber auch virtuell betreiben die fifa
2018 online spiele gegen andere spieler
wenn wir das ganze virtuelle realisiert
an der andere weise mehr passieren und
dieser fand eine andere weise würde
bedeuten dass ist konzeption zur
freiheit denn und zwar negativen
verhältnis sind frei von raum und zeit
ich bin frei davon
ich bin nicht angewiesen auf die
öffnungszeiten dieser halle auf den
rasen zustand dass die negativen
freiheit von frei
zum ich kann es auch an der an und
abreise denn die sind in cyberspace ging
antritt
der menschliche freiheit akteure habe
ich so ein bisschen ersten und zweiten
engagieren sie kennen diese erscheinung
schon erste natur sagt man dass die
physikalisch chemisch biologisch
beschreibt das wurde auch streng der
terminierte durch naturgesetz zweiten
touristik kultur und häufig sagt man ja
gut die zweite hat unsere kultur kann
ich direkt reduziert werden auf die
erste natur
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel moral ist ja
auch zum phänomen der zweiten natur
wenn ich im wahl auf die natur hier ist
die natur reduzieren will
die moral biologisch erklären kann ich
machen dass der revolutionäre ethik aber
eher evolutionär relativ würde bedeuten
letztendlich hat der steuerkredit
stärken
kurz gesagt setzt sich halt durch und
alles muss dem fortschritt untergeordnet
werden und die schwächeren können wir
dann halt im zweifel
irgendwie weiß ich was beseitigt und
solche möglichen gab es ja dann
sozialdarwinismus wer gerade so anfang
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts im
faschistischen ideologie ihnen sind 1900
bis 1940 50 watt das total im trend
sozialer in
und das serviceteam der versuch die
zweite natur auf die erste natur zu
reduzieren also mit
naturwissenschaftlichen methoden und zur
kulturelles leben zu gestalten und das
ist natürlich fatal dienstag
ich will damit nicht sagen dass er nicht
auch die biologie mit einbeziehen muss
aber sie gibt uns nicht die normalen
morgen vor die wir im interagieren es
wird sehr schnell gefährlich dann wenn
wir alles den vermeintlichen natürlichen
fortschritt und die ohren und zum
beispiel ist so etwas wie mitleid wusste
was sich tun denn eben gar nicht mehr
danach könnt gegenüber jemand wer krank
ist oder schwach ist nicht was auch mit
der natur hat kein betrag natur kennt
kein mitleid ist eine rein soziale und
kulturelle entwicklungen viele sagen
jetzt seine christentum würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen aber es gab auch zeiten
wurden
mit oder ohne gespielt hat es jedenfalls
als kulturelles naturgesetze wäre es um
wahlgesetze freiheits gesetze müssen
unterschreiben
es gibt immer versuche die immer
eingesetzt dass das saarland als sollens
gelb aus der natur zu reduzieren ist
verlockend weil man eben das alles durch
einen prinzip erklären kann
und so hat man die massen tourismus
natur versus freiheit natur das sein
erstes soll das philosophisch durchaus
unbefriedigend man will ja alles immer
von der gemeinsame wurde zurück
das wirklich verraten
wo sind die ganzen stadt würde ich
einfach naturgesetzen selbst sage ich
auch hingehe
einfach nur von der möglichkeit
gesprochen dass abzugrenzen was nicht
innerhalb der sprache etwas zögerlich
und das ist der entscheidende
unterschied zum beispiel auch die
positiven vorhersagen eigentlich in
diesem ko-spiel stuhl logisch dass
verschiedene varianten von uns zur
beschreibung der tätigkeiten der
beschreibung ist ja also sie haben
sicherlich recht dass man kritisch
auseinandersetzen muss mit so was wie
der natur dem naturgesetz ist es auch
gar nicht fragen und olympischen status
natur bis hin zu terminieren sie
wirklich alles kann ich alles
neurologisch detektiv wo es einem das
eine anzahl von
ich habe die welt das ist und die
kondition und wird er ist die liste
gesetzt wie nur dass die bell zum als
ähnlich wie einst aus er kann die aus
der kombination keltenwelt zustands zu
einer bestimmten zeit mit dem dort
herrschenden gesetzen kann ich
herausfinden zieren die medien mails
zustand dass sie damit die bekannte
wiederbeleben andere zeit und das ist
auch nicht so klar ob das überhaupt
die naturgesetze wirklich so
determinieren und dann ist die frage was
ist ein naturgesetz welchen status hat
werden wir bekommen ja nur mit chemische
kenntnisse über experimente also wir
installierte induktion wir haben so
viele mag das beobachtet dass der
standort erkennt
wir können das natürlich physikalisch
auch errechnen aber mir scheint das
ganze nicht a priori möglich zu sein
also nur logisch reduziert
immer wenn er von den gesetzen spricht
auch erfahren
hängt das ganze aus diesem papier in der
luft weil es eben induktiv geworden ist
riesen spannende frage bei rein
philosophisch bisher man es gibt eben
dinge die nicht mit unserer freiheit zu
tun haben die natur des etwas tailliert
und das ist das worum wir uns selbst
bestimmen
man kann man das durchaus auch die
überstimmt wird seit frage kann
digitalität auf der zweite natur kultur
reduziert werden oder gibt es ihr
reduzierte phänomen der digitalität dies
verhindern
das ist die spannende frage ob es wie es
wie es damit aussieht und ich würde
sagen ich hatte ja ein paar thesen dass
es phänomene die sich nicht reduzieren
lassen
auf die zweite natur was auch immer die
zweite natur hier ist mein argument war
folgendes ich habe sie ich sehe man auch
in etwa folgendes dass wir es eben hier
und der der dritten achse nennen hier
mit solchen
zu tun auch zb mit der objektivierung
und auch viel stärker noch mit ihren
träumen derzeitigen einseitig die zweite
mit kultur hat ein sehr langes langes
raumzeit verständnis auf dem es passiert
und diese verteilung diese vernetzung
diese endlich wieder unsere inserenten
größeres direkte assoziationen die ist
etwas neues was wir in der
traditionellen kultur sagt man nicht
haben sich der sprecher auf der
hundewiese dass einige zurückgekommen
das passiert das alles jahr was einer
folge trugen aber auch einfach
die auf das heißt einfach nur komisch
temperaturen die eigentlichen grund sind
immer erst würde es ohne namen waren sie
überhaupt unseres menschen verständliche
hier zb wir sprachen haben möchte und
bankenkommission interview auf eine
höhere beteiligung sollten wir brauchen
unsere afghanischen alltag dass wir
stehen da das statement gegenüber setzt
sich immer eine große gefahr dass auf
jeden fall nicht dieses dasein des
meeres möglichkeit zum beispiel diese
algorithmen zieht auf die hersteller zu
sprechen kommen das scheint mir sowas zu
sein was es in der zeit natürlich gibt
diese immer aufbereitung die automatisch
im hintergrund läuft dieses ganzen
filtersysteme oder auch die neuronalen
netze die da irgendwas aus
kristallisieren ist das abnehmen ist das
ganze vorbereitung dann würde ich auch
sagen ist in der digitalität einen
kooperations komplexität gegeben die um
einen welche qualitativen viel was sich
von der dance beiden ganze
unterscheidung würde sagen kultur hat es
immer nur einem sehr begrenzten
informationen zu tun und ihre
organisation kultur beherrscht immer
noch über sieht die informationen die
traditionelle kultur digitalität
hingegen hat sich damit abgefunden dass
informationen übersichtlich geworden ist
also wir sind permanent überfordert in
den himmel der digitalität weil
prinzipien alles als information gelten
kann und was als information geht es
deshalb vornherein nicht ausgemacht die
daten für das so großen es hängt davon
ab wie sie auch bereit und wie wir
unsere 19 trainieren ich glaube dass das
noch was wird bekannt dass es alles kann
prinzipiell
sie gelten und es kommen nur auf den
kontext anprobieren diese daten
interpretiert und wie wir sie in
verarbeiten dürfen wir sie aufhalten und
dass er auch noch zum antrag und genau
das ist der punkt ist dass wir
eigentlich eine maschine gebaut haben
nur unsere fähigkeit also fragt ist eben
diese maschine zu beschreiben
unseren teil zu beschreiben die
opposition hat das endlich unsere
sprache besonders einfach
juli
das heißt nicht automatisch
hier ist das system ist eine
systematische frage ja technisch gesehen
sicherlich das militärische seite um die
frage wäre jetzt irgendwie sich das dann
auf der lebensweltliche neben und auf
der ontologischen ebene die auf der
interaktiven ebene mit als gesichter
auswirken ich habe jetzt ihre position
auf gezeigt als es komplett
individualisieren mit kommen noch mal
genau auf was ich damit meine
und es ist teilen das scheint mir auch
was spezifisches zu sein was zur die
vitalität gehört vernetzung vermittlung
alles ist prinzipiell interessant und
alles kann prinzipiell reaktionen die
wir in jedes beliebige und alles
wer stellt schon alles kann neue
neologismen ich würde es mal so ein
bisschen genauer klären habe ich jetzt
eben dem stall das und drei kategorien
entgegen nicht entgegengesetzt und ich
habe versucht seine kategorien der
digitalität der kultur also referenz
realität algorithmen zitiert
gemeinschaftlichkeit leben aber jetzt
hier gefällt es so ein bisschen gegen
diese instrumente subjektivität in der
objektivität bedeutet wirklich wir
können alles und gegenstand machen und
werden selbst zum gegenstand was aber
nichts problematisches aber wir uns nach
außen öffnen uns wird extern analysieren
das hängt mit dem zweiten transportieren
die externalisierung
[Musik]
extra und dann eben noch dieser raum und
zeitlosigkeit und damit meine ich nicht
dass es nicht in die keinen raum
bedeutung mehr hat aber es ist eine
andere logik des raumes die hypertext
werfen auch eine räumlichkeit aber eine
andere
es ist die kultur kennt und zwar wie
floridis sagte in einem werk hat das
gesagt diese fehlen die reibung ist
schreibt sich nicht mehr raum und zeit
der zweite natur die ist mit reibung
behaftet gut radio hat schon durch die
radiowellen diese tendenz der reifen
zentrierten aber diese völlige
reibungslos tk die sekundenbruchteil und
diese überhaupt herrscht und
übernächsten für die passiert gerade
das würde ich ihn mit diesem trick mit
der versuchung zu bezeichnen und das
ergibt dann eine zusammenspiel eine ganz
andere logik auch technologisch ist und
das ist eben meine these durch die
digitalisierung befreien lebens und der
ersten und damit meine ich wir sind
angewiesen auf grauen zeitgrenzen kann
ist wir sind nicht mehr so vor
unternehmen brauchen wir können sie
anders realisieren
wir präsentieren lesen anders meinte
positive freiheit also digitalisierung
die technische seite wer die negativen
fall wir machen uns unabhängig von raum
und zeit negativ freiheit von
digitalität werde den positiven die
freiheit zu anders zu realisieren als in
der ersten
und dann habe ich jetzt versuchen die
digitalität als fall der virtualität
bezeichnung der virtualität darunter
fällt auch geld geldscheine die mit
digital sind aber sie sind die
anderswelt ist wird von unternehmen
starten nationen usw
rituelle entitäten aber eben nicht
digitale virtuelle identitäten und dann
bin ich auf dieses oxford herren und
natürlich
gegangen und das sagte diesem zitat ich
hab es auch hier repräsentiert die sagen
hier dass das virtuelle viel weiter
zurückreicht als die moderne digitale
technik also geldscheine es weiter
sofort existierten schon vor der
erfindung der virtuellen auch nur schön
wenn man die besonderen muss schon in
der steinzeit die als die werte sind
reduziert hat nicht dass in diesem
beispiel die schecks geldscheine während
ein natürlicher juristische person
juristische person finde ich dort auch
spannung um juristische fest
wir behandeln die biene personen also
mit rechten und pflichten gewissermaßen
auch die frage ob eine natürliche person
also wir zum beispiel die wir hier in
dem raum sitzen und wir virtuell extrem
spannende frei als personen virtuelle
ich würde sagen schon weil was zeigt
eine person aus was würden sie sagen die
bestimmen sie dann natürlich der eine
person wie man zu gemeinde von ihr
spricht eine person definieren zurück
was macht mit personen
im unterschied zu mensch und wir sagen
alle menschen sind personen aber was ist
erforderlich damit etwas als eine person
gemacht werden kann
[Musik]
denken sie mal so ethischer hinsicht das
kritische stimmen
zb die würde er die behörde der person
in aldersbach und dann kann man sich ja
aber wo ist denn die würde der person
wie sieht sie aus wie groß ist die würde
schauen sie ich habe einen schock ich
bin 1 meter 80 groß wie zwischen 70 und
80 kilogramm je nach tageszeit oder je
nach jahreszeit
das sind eigenschaften die mich als
mensch bestimmen nicht unbedingt
wesentlich aber die funktionen gehören
jetzt sage ich habe auch noch er würde
können sie fragen wie große dem würde
die schwere investiert würde sie am
linken wahlrecht beim herz und gehirn wo
ist die würde und das meine ich damit
dass noch damit von einer virtualität
sprechen können als die würde der person
wenn sie wie sie uns ja eine person wenn
sie eine person ist die muss nicht als
80 sein kann er und weiß ich könnte auch
zehn zentimeter größer und personen mit
behörden ist nicht abhängig von selbst
ist es nicht abhängig von unserer
menschlichen gestalt es wäre möglich
dass außerirdische wesen gibt die auch
personen sind gemeinhin sagt man das
sind freie ws diesen wesentlich
selbstbewusstsein haben die sich selbst
bestimmen können das im personen- und
erfährt man ja wohl hängt
wo ist ihre vierteln und das wollte ich
dass dessen obmann könnte man sagen
würde ist das virtuelles die würde der
person hängt nicht mit ihren
eigenschaften ab die sich hier ist weiß
ich gar nicht körperlich sind die würde
ist etwas was wir erst im internet
aktiven vom bund ihr zugeschrieben wird
aber auch aufrechterhalten und das ist
dann das thema der sozial- und ton geben
sonst stimmt die renditen realitäten wie
zum beispiel würde
oder wie geld geld währungen geldwerte
die nicht natürlich vorliegen sind erst
dann existieren und zwar wirklich also
wie h mit causa angriff der billigkeit
wenn es dir eine gesellschaft
und so glaube ich wie ein geldschein ein
wert besitzt der verbindlich ist genau
so hat auch eine person würde defekt ist
wenn neben eine hinreichend große
soziale das garantiert das heißt man
muss dagegen auch das gleiche wenn man
eine hürde zu spielen auch zugleich
dafür sorgen dass die wirte verteidigt
wird das heißt dort endlich
institutionelle macht exekutive
legislative usw einer sozialsystem was
erst dann so was wie eine frieden
ermöglicht ich würde sagen auch würde
also um es hier auch die würde
der sohn bernhard klein oder würden sie
sagen dass volkstanz volkswagen wäre das
das unternehmen volkswagen als
juristische oder die universität als
juristische person würde hat überlegen
sie mal kurz frage ist gar nicht so
trivial oder ein staat
ich weiß nicht ob man statt als
touristisch pressionen sind
wahrscheinlich nicht im kamin ist aber
kein staat hat so ein bisschen was
ähnliches linien universität und wie
unternehmen symbole den staat hat eine
flasche das erlebnis immer wenn ich die
lmu flagge verbrennen würde hier wäre
dann die würde der juristischen person
der universität verletzt dadurch gegen
die schuld bisschen oder also viele von
uns wird die lmu die für jäger geben sie
mal über den usa
das sieht ganz anders aus wenn sie das
in so einem college haben oder harvard
university
wenn sie dann diese fahne von harvard
eine fürstliche verbrennen
da wird es dann schon virulente da
würden sich glaube ich einige schon auf
gedrängt fühlen weil sie sich so sehr
mit dieser institution identifizieren
und ich glaube dass diese kränkung
nur psychologisch natur ich glaube ich
dass es ihre virtuelle virtuelle
realität werden hier würden wirklich
soziale die athleten geschafft die
nächstenliebe und seiner würde sagen
scheinen als ich zum essen deutsche
universitätssystem geprägt sein soll
seine rolle fahren ist nur so mit lacken
was regt euch dann auf
ja
[Musik]
genau
genau das sieht man dass man im usa hat
die universität sogar eine exekutive
partiell ich will mir jetzt nicht er war
das fenster lehnen aber die hier diverse
die aus chicago hatten eigene polizei
ist er jetzt mal unter uns so vorsichtig
diesen stark bewacht gab es selbst
gesehen ja also ich war eine zeitlang
chicago universität und diese haben also
einen ordentlich machen dann können
unsere polizisten nicht dagegen ankommt
vielleicht sogar fast ein bisschen was
in den exekutiven nicht direkt jetzt
aber so eine schutzmacht die sie auf dem
campus gemacht auch schaden ohne
gewissen im kontext der
staatengemeinschaft muss also
gepflogenheiten herrschen wie man
miteinander umgeht beziehungsweise wie
man nicht mit meiner genesung ist das
auch schon in einer art würde ja immer
vor 17 uhr ein symbol es nicht nur eine
fiktion inklusion
ich will jetzt seine politische gehen
aber verbrennen sie eine beliebige
flagge eines beliebigen start
das ist nicht trivial das ist nicht
ideal
man hört ja mit opera angenommen
genau und brauchen da gar nicht sie
können sich alles dabei denken kann man
beliebig austauschen dort wird die und
dort die die verbringen sich gegen so
richtig lag
das ist nicht trivial weil ich glaube
nicht dass es nun an dem psychologische
wirkung ist das hinterhalt derjenige auf
der anderen seite des pazifiks oder
atlantiks gekränkt fühlt sich glauben da
wird wirklich so ein bisschen und logie
betrieben aus nichtwissen senkung der
mann verstecken würde nicht würdig seine
starten würde haben aber sehr wohl zu
holen die man auf eine bestimmte weise
erwärmen verwenden kann
deren kritische behörde stellte
verwendung wenn durchaus auch politisch
stellte mir vor bei einem staatsempfang
eines x-beliebigen alex beliebigen
präsidentin würden sie dann aufs
rollfeld auf dem roten teppich und die
fahne dieser nation zerreißt ich glaube
nicht dass das ich glaube dass das
durchaus eben juristisch insofern
problematischer wäre als die da
irgendwie unruhe gestiftet haben
sein vize reisen dies erfahren
die eine gewisse kommen oder eine
gewisse verletzung vorgenommen ich bin
kein jurist aber mir scheint prima fazit
da eine gewisse ontologie mit einer
sozial
[Musik]
gute karten haben weil sie mich dieses
beschäftigen zumindest ein feld nur eine
komplette über jeden spieler hat er
nicht mehr in der lage ist es überaus
zukunft des anderen zu verstehen dass
sie seien sich zusammen kein staat
geregelt wird und so weiter entschieden
sind die beziehungen zwischen diesen
fragen sind einmal das heißt statt
zitierte richtig welchen startbereit und
wir haben vielleicht die im gesetz
verdeck gedanken und gefühlen sind nicht
vorsätzlich es auch der einen bisherigen
heute welchem letzten wichtigsten
entscheider dass es den staat aus sehr
vielen leuten wir mussten das beim start
ihres zustands ist es manchmal absprache
ok in den mannschaftswagen weil selbst
anzunehmen aber es ist ihr möchtet
einiges hören gewesen
gut sie vertreten dann völlig legitim
touristisches sich sagen mit dem start
alle sind die themen gibt so nicht es
gibt nur die individuen die sich
dazugehörig zählen
und das geht eben kennt die jungs haben
es nun schon eine ganze minute auch
sprach und der vertreter eben genau die
gegen gesetze diese zwiebeln der sarg
mit der sprache und seine kollegen
intensität mit der sprache auch mit
performativ akten liegt sollen so was
wie hier mit nenne ich dich und so er
sagt mit solchen sprachlichen
performative pragmatisch liegenschaften
den neuen themen er würde glauben
hingegen wir sind die sache zu sagen
wieviele st die sprache erzeugt
verbindliche die themen die nicht nur
reduziert werden können das sind dann
ist das mit der axt und es ist nicht
unrealistisch ich meinen hut vor der
höhe unterscheidung obrigkeit sprachlos
behindern müssen begreifen so weiter
bestimmte prozesse aus unserem team
haben alles geht es nicht nur dass ich
irgendwie start zu gehen
es geht auch darum dass andere
gegnerschaft gegen cdu gerieten dass es
nun selber teilt die stadt interessant
das heißt es besteht also darin komplexe
abhängigkeitsverhältnissen zb bekommen
verlieren können und so wunderbar fällt
irgendwann auch die kommunikation
darüber dass es nicht problemfrei sind
es entscheidend sich zum reduzierten zu
sehen aus wie entstehen das im kasten
um diesen verbindungen ja genommen aber
auch wirklich nur das ihn
wiederzubeleben verbindung das heißt es
ist eines unserer obersten grenze was
ist hier das ist nicht unsere form sogar
jetzt ein klares und umgebung genau ich
glaube dass du den richtigen punkt haben
und zb wir sehen es einfach mal hier
diese blaue party und nun ist das
passiert worauf sparen aber er existiert
trotzdem und was sie es damit
wahrscheinlich mein überhaupt war es so
leistet man kann unterscheiden realität
wirklichkeit situation für diskussion
und ich habe hier diese dieser sicht
noch mal und dann stark während das
virtuell ist der an dass diese zutaten
stein bestens weit medizin verstanden
wird sagen hat ein staat hat andere
existenzbedingungen als einstein
existenzbedingungen selbst wenn es keine
menschen gäbe würde an zu stellen sie
vor allem menschen sollen jetzt
ausgelöscht werden
da würde doch diese universitäten oder
soll man dieses diese fernbedienung in
der mentalität immer noch investieren
also ich würde sagen die resistenzen
eines baumes draußen es gibt keine
menschen mehr auf der welt selbst gar
keine freien zu mir keine erster sind
anwesen
würden sie sagen diese baum draußen
würde noch existieren es keine freien
lesen gegeben
ganz so als würde ich sagen mehr sagt
sie existieren ob der baum existiert er
sagte mir ist irrt nicht mehr gut warum
nicht wollte sagen ich reihe mich
bestmöglich in einer einfachen
definition es gibt eine möglichkeit
müssen alles mobilisieren
das heißt es und musikalisch das problem
in der gerade die möglichkeit da werde
ich mich ganz schön höhe bewegungsmangel
nämlich sagen was ist mit den vielen
lobenden worten und halt machen
beschreibt und so weiter für diesen baum
diesem existieren weil der hintersten
eigentlich wissen dass helme möglichkeit
das heißt ich kann selber beschreiben
aber ob es das testierte oder gar nicht
so schwer ist und ich wissen weil ich
reich existiert ist meine aufnahmen
befanden sich zb projektion ist hingegen
das bedeutet dass objekte im april ihren
anderen zu stellen sind und deswegen
nahm mit allen stärken und zu fördern so
lief es endlich möglich sein sich hier
behaupten das weil ich kann mich jetzt
gut überhaupt erreichbar des moduls das
ist überhaupt war es gibt ok genau
jemand das ist die frage
realismus imitieren ist der westen
würden sagen physikalische und blickte
auf bäume existieren nur sofern subjekte
gibt es die sie prinzipiell wahrnehmen
die über sie reden können und das sind
idealisten die machen die existenz
rauchen eigentlich physikalischen
unabhängigen dingen abhängig von
suitcase dass ein oder zwei der gibson
streitpunkt man die entweder sozusagen
die liste sei es musste einen weg geben
erst dann kannst dir sagt geben müssen
manche würden sagen wir brauchen zwei
objekte damit es auch physikalische
stelle geben kann und die realisten
sagen nein bäume materielle gegenständen
existieren auch wenn es keine probleme
gibt die sie wahrnehmen würde gespräche
oder darüber nachdenkt das ist die
spannende frage
der idealismus hat ein bisschen was den
ersten kontrahenten
man nimmt nach dem sonnen in dem
natürlich seien seine existenz die man
völlig physikalisch gestalten
vor irgendwelchen zu blicken anders ist
es aber ich denke dass wir uns einig mit
universitäten und mit unternehmen mit
blauen partien
wenn es da keine subjekt dem ergibt die
für diesen wert bürger die fragen
liefert objekte muss es geben damit das
virtuelle realität geben kann
das würde ich sagen 123 wir sind uns ja
eigentlich das virtuelle realitäten nur
der intercity verbindung zustande kommen
so zu sagen wieviele muss es leben gibt
es objekte wie vieles wie groß muss die
gesellschaft seien mindestens damit es
wird über die realitäten geben kann
eine gar nicht mehr frei kann man das
große debatte ich persönlich habe mir
auch mal jetzt gedanken macht ich würde
sagen es ist unentschieden auf 1233
selbst drei halte ich für möglichen
kandidaten ich will es kurz mal
begründen also manche sagen es reicht
ein subjekt das sind die idealisten die
er in der tradition des
deutschlandtourismus existieren dieter
henrich kennt ihr schon jemand von
hinten mit einem mittlerweile sehr
betagt dafür sorgt
sich der lange zeit hier gewirkt 70 80
und 80er und der sound war stellung
orange norden überhaupt werde die hsg
des keils objekt einzugehen besser als
sprach sogar von einem transzendentalen
robinson worin zum kloster ein
alleiniges einzug liegt reicht um die
moralische ordnung herzustellen
die verbindlichkeiten der moralischen
ordnung gibt eben die anderen ihren die
kommunikativen sind vielleicht jürgen
habermas und gegenspieler ist noch so
kleine sehr betagte herren dieser
mindestens zwei robert spaemann ist auch
noch so ein philosoph hier gelebt hat er
würde das auch sagen personen gibt es
nur mit meinte wahrscheinlich 2 ich
glaube sogar dass man argumente dafür
anführen kann dass es drei geben muss
und 2001 gedanke folgende nachfolgender
stellen sie haben dann im personal oder
menschen der nicht sprechen kann der
nicht die personalen eigenschaften
aufweist
das selbstbewusstsein zugunsten kranker
mensch im internet oder so
ja wer es dort dafür dass der noch eine
person ist er selbst ja nicht dann kann
sich ja nicht setzen durch sein zu
fiktiven tätig und das ist so mein
gegangen ich glaube fast dass man drei
pressungen ansetzen muss eben auch
solche predigen dass personen die
mächtiger sogar an eigenschaften
aufweisen
das geht einmal zu und zwar dank dieser
diese version ist die sie auch im
virtuellen raum zum version erheben
deswegen wir denn so eine these die
jetzt investieren möchte gebrauchen 33
jetzt können sie sagen sein
wir brauchen vier will aber sie am 12
und damit bin ich übrigens nur so
nebenbei theologisch irgend auch in
seiner tradition gibt ja auch dass die
drei besten aber das jetzt neu
anzufangen
zusagen zur echten leben beste zu sein
stellte das ist auch dass also das ist
ein sehr schönes braucht also sagen dass
man in großen zeitungen selbst nicht
lästig wieder sein ok geben ja ich
meinte dass jetzt auch nicht nur mehr
bestellt ich meine damit ihre qualität
also auch nicht jetzt graduelle ist weil
von der kunst wie muss die grundstruktur
sein müssen zwei sein und es kann auch
sein dass sich der mix
im halben jahr aber wie groß muss die
die konstellation sein wie mächtig muss
die konstellation des netzes seien des
sozialen netzes damit überhaupt wie
lange auch immer geltung entstehen kann
die geltung kann auch eine halbe stunde
dauern und sagte er persönlich machen
mit aber die frage ist wie viele
personen ist und mir scheint immer mehr
betreiben also warten wir vorne des
herzmuskels dieses diesem grund weil es
eben in frage oder auch für eine
technologisch die intuition und wir
haben für eine etwas was für eine person
nennen wollen könnte grund dafür haben
aber dieses etwas dieses subjekt keine
selbst mit seit wir müssen
stellvertretend für dessen es tun und
diese repräsentation ihr repräsentiert
ist wird schon wieder
und dazu brauchen wir zwei die es ihm
den euro gespannt plus dieses dritte was
daneben da ein erhoben wird
es gibt da einen vortrag von maria
jackman die vom personal space
gesprochen hat macht er auch kuchen
rechts noch
den link reinfurt an dem sie
thailändisch und ich glaube dass man das
zu reformieren können ich möchte es aber
auch mit dem nutzer diskussion stellen
mit einer nicht definitiv am ende mit
glaube drei so meine in einem kranken
einfach mit ja das ist hier gibt es auch
eine mögliche weitere guten kollegen die
jeden ergebniszahlen hat jetzt ein paar
toni katholische dem saal unterscheiden
konnte früh gesagt der gedanke existiert
objektiv gedanke inhalt von an gedanken
dass das wetter wird schön und auch die
realität ist auto warten weiter auf den
konzern und den dritten punkt zum
schluss möchten aufbringen
man könnte noch zwischen realität und
wirklichkeit unterscheiden und zwei
folgende maßnahmen könnt ihr nur
aufmachen
wirklichkeit und möglichkeiten und auch
wer elitäre und realität würden darunter
wirklichkeit und hier wäre ich glücklich
damit wie ich sagen es gibt wirkliche
fiktionen und es gibt mögliche
reaktionen
es gibt wirkliche simulationen und es
gibt mögliches innovationen wenn ich
fifa 95 gegen die computerspiele handelt
sich dabei um eine wirkliche simulation
wenn auch nicht um eine reaktion
es gibt aber auch mögliche simulationen
ich könnte jetzt hier 95 spielen wäre es
eine möglichste aber keine aktuellen
wird so könnte man auch noch zusätzlich
schafft unterscheiden würden wir auf die
realität einfach nicht möglich weil es
eben eine wirkliche realität ist eine
wirkliche illusion ich werde jetzt
wirklich getäuscht
wirklich eine fata morgana ist ein
wirklich sind es gebe auch eine mögliche
vater madonna hier könnt ihr jetzt
plötzlich im freien eine fata morgana
entstehen werden sie nun möglich und so
kann man auch noch zusätzlich zwischen
realität und wirklichkeit und der
scheibe bei der unterscheidung
interessant ist also sinnlos weil wird
damit auch nichts anderes mehr haben zu
essen
aber wenn man es hier um die eigenen
kunden oder wirklichkeit nehmen
unternehmen noch die möglichkeit
erhalten ist und das wäre noch die
letzte schauen sie das angestellt ich
vorhin auch immer runter ich verlinke
auch noch am schluss hier oben rechts
meinen vortrag noch mal rein
über dieses die briten mit diskussionen
können sich um rein schauen
ich glaube auch zum schluss dass das
internet das paradies meiner die
mentalität ist es ist kein medium der
weg sei es die bedingung der möglichkeit
von medialität des wortes transfer
italien
es ermöglicht ist den raum ist eröffnet
den raum von hashtags von sprecher von
youtube usw
es ist ein grundbedürfnis dem wasser
strom und wärme geworden und nicht fast
freiheits kontext auf in dem sich
virtuelle realität bis zu ereignen kann
über 34 der bezug pädagogische
perspektiven internet kann verbindlichen
lehren von text darstellen wir sind hier
dabei am versuchen in dem moment wo ich
das sage versuche ich immer mit anderen
auch einen neuen kontext zu schaffen ein
digitalität es mehr kostet dem wir
lernen transformieren
reform hin entwickeln und ich glaube
eben das lernen zeit eine vitalität
nichts mit simulationen
wir simulieren hier nicht den
traditionellen frontalunterricht wir
versuchen hier zu transformieren
eine ganz neue form zu geben und
vernetzung schreiben hier auch ganz
zu diesem neuen kontext dann wünsche ich
ihnen ein schönes wochenende
bis zur nächsten sitzung der wir uns mit
dem thema anthologie der digitalität
noch mal auseinandersetzen dann